i've got good news and i've got bad news
let's start with the bad news the bad
news is that the trump administration
has begun the formal transition process
to the biden administration in a limited
way
but it has begun the transition process
bad news the good news president trump
still has not conceded the election
the good news there is still a long
legal process that needs to play out
the good news bush fee gore took 38 days
we're on day
21 of all this and then the shocking
news is there is somehow a more
disturbing transition going on in this
country
even than the one that's going on in the
white house this one
involves gender ideology and kids we'll
get into all of it i'm michael knowles
that's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from thefrogprince89
who says governor cuomo is about to
receive
an emmy award for leadership during the
pandemic
aren't emmys supposed to be awarded to
actors
does this mean that cuomo was just
playing the role of a good governor
excellent analysis of this yes and our
entertainment sector
is playing the role of an entertainment
sector and our
liberal political elite are playing the
role of politicians and actually
our real political life is being made by
a staler a less constitutional
bureaucratic edifice which actually joe
biden is showing us
as his transition begins very
discouraging news though the fight is
not yet over why did this begin
in part i suspect it began because
yesterday the
michigan board of canvassers certified
the state
for joe biden so the process as we elect
the president is
you go out and you vote or this time you
don't go out and you vote you
you write your name on a piece of paper
and then you send it in and some
crook in a democratic machine city
decides how and what to count
and then you know they go out to the
graveyards and they dig up a number of
democratic voters and they say okay go
make sure
we want to make sure that you're
enfranchised as well so i don't know
that's just how i'm imagining this
process plays out
we don't know for sure i suppose the
legal process will show us in any event
you go out and you vote
and then the numbers come in and then
that that does not decide who gets the
electoral votes
the state needs to certify the winner of
the election which has not happened in
michigan
up until this point there were
republican members of this election
board
who were going to delay this and now
they stopped delaying it so michigan's
election board voted three
in favor and one abstaining to certify
the state's election results
which means that michigan goes to joe
biden
it is not impossible for donald trump to
get michigan now but it's
it's very difficult uh you could have a
situation in which the court
overturns this certification of of the
the vote
but it's historically speaking seems
pretty unlikely
the trump administration for their part
has
begun to acquiesce to a transition
process
this began with the gsa the
one of the administrative agencies in
the government
emily murphy who is the administrator of
the u.s general services
administration says that she has quote
the ability under the presidential
transition act of 1963 as amended
to make certain post-election resources
and services available to assist in the
event
of a presidential transition and
therefore she was going to do this
now emily murphy had been getting a lot
of
death threats and things like that
because she had not begun the transition
process
already now i suspect she's going to get
a lot of hate from
conservatives who wish wish that she
does not
begin this transition process um emily
murphy writes i have dedicated much of
my life
to public service i've always strived to
do what is right
please know that i came to my decision
independently based on the law and
available facts i was never directly or
indirectly pressured
by any executive branch official
including those who work at the white
house or the gsa
with regard to the substance or timing
of my decision now what she's saying is
trump didn't bully me into making my
decision he didn't
bully me either into
going for this you know going and
starting the transition or bullying me
into not starting the transition she's
saying i made this independently
as a member of the bureaucracy and she's
saying this as though it were a good
thing
i don't think that's a good thing i
think that the duly elected president
should be making these sorts of
decisions i don't think that an
independent bureaucracy so-called
independent
bureaucracy should be making these
decisions for the duly elected president
it's a complete misunderstanding
of how our government works and it
affects the left and
the right but president trump had a
surprising reaction
to to this move we were all waiting for
the angry
tweets and that's that's not exactly
what we
saw you know all of the uh all of the
threats this woman
was getting on the internet i think we
can probably relate to because your data
is not always secure
this holiday season you could miss
certain identity threats by just
monitoring your credit and bank
statements get lifelock the leader in
identity theft protection
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats like your social
security number for sale on the dark web
if they detect your information being
used in their network they will send you
an alert
if you become a victim of identity theft
lifelock can help you restore your
identity easier than what you can do
on your own it's very easy for people to
steal your information online
you have got to be the one who is
responsible for protecting your data i
know i used to be like this i used to
think
ah no one's coming for my data they are
and you're much more vulnerable i think
like i'm not particularly computer
literate i didn't realize how vulnerable
i was now obviously no one can prevent
all identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses
but lifelock can help you feel protected
this holiday season
the best sale of the year is happening
right now save up to 30 percent off your
first year
at lifelock.com knowles k-w-l-e-s
that is 30 percent you're never going to
get that anywhere 30
off at lifelock.com slash knowles sale
ends
november 30th president trump i was
waiting for the flurry of angry tweets
at the gsa administrator but that's not
what happened president trump actually
backed her up
and he was very gracious about it and he
said she's done a good job and he really
supports her
and she's making some resources
available to the presidential transition
but she's not he rather is not going to
concede the election
just yet it's a little bit of a mixed
message
i have to say i wish that the president
would not begin the transition process i
wish and i who knows maybe
this gsa administrator is being honest
here
when she says she made the decision
independently she should not make the
decision independently she should not be
permitted
to make the decision independently the
decision of whether or not to concede an
election and beginning
the transition process is in a
limited way a concession a partial
concession
that decision should be made by the
president alone
not by some bureaucrat i don't care if
it's a lovely bureaucrat who served in
the government all her life i don't care
the president should make that decision
and i do wish
that the president we're not acquiescing
i i'm appreciative
that he's still keeping up the fight he
still says he's going to be filing major
lawsuits in the coming
a week or two still going to duke this
out until the end
but i wish i wish there were no
acquiescence whatsoever
there is a legal process that will play
out
michigan is going to certify the vote
okay that's a knock that's too bad
georgia is going to certify that's too
bad
legal options are narrowing okay that's
fine
but there is no reason to give in to
these left-wing bullies or insisting
that we
not use every legal remedy available
there's no reason to suggest that it is
overturning constitutional norms to
allow the legal process to play out
the left who are now prattling on about
constitutional norms
have spent six months burning the
country to the ground
and openly telling us they would not
respect the results of the election
hillary clinton openly saying
joe biden should not concede under any
circumstances i do not want to be
lectured by these people on
constitutional norms
particularly when we conservatives are
the ones
who are following them joe biden may
well ascend to the presidency we'll find
out
on december 14th when the electors vote
that's that that will determine it we'll
know and in january
we'll have a president and maybe that
president will have ascended fair and
square maybe that president will have
ascended through fraud
i don't know but either way we will have
a president i think back
when people have asked if if joe biden
you know does win
and there is a lot of evidence of fraud
let's say should we accept him as the
president i do think back
to the many stolen elections throughout
history and the many stolen transitions
of power
i go back forget even just in american
history go back to 1688
in the united kingdom the analogy i like
to use is
when in 1688 when they depose the good
king james ii
and they bring in these interlopers
william and mary of orange
i think those interlopers are completely
illegitimate i think the proper king of
englanders are the descendants of king
james the second
who are prattling about you know they're
running around in france or
liechtenstein somewhere
nevertheless queen elizabeth is the
queen of england right that's
that is just a description of reality so
we may have to deal with
a president that we don't like or who we
who we think won
through nefarious means but we don't
have to do it yet guys
this was my show yesterday i think i
might be the last patient man in america
we should absolutely exhaust every
option available to us now if
the biden transition does happen if
biden does become president
boy oh boy are we in for it joe biden
has announced from the
vaunted office of the president-elect
that he has
given himself he announced that he's
going to put john kerry
the failed secretary of state into a new
position in his administration he will
make him
the climate czar the climate czar i
didn't know there was a climate czar i
guess there isn't one
but now there will be i suppose john
kerry will be in charge of
manipulating science to make all of our
political decisions for us
outside of the authentic realm of
politics
what this tells me what this signals to
me this one appointment of john kerry
is that the biden administration if it
occurs
will be the coronavirus lockdown on
steroids
it will be an administration of
coronavirus lockdowns not just
not specifically with regard to
coronavirus or the lockdown but broadly
to the idea
that we are going to have our politics
dictated to us by egghead idiots in
white lab coats
who are then interpreted by politicians
who want to pretend that they're not
being politicians
and the the rules that come out of the
biden administration are going to
all have the sheen and patina of science
on it
this is something the left has been
doing for now about 150 years
they say no our our political
preferences they're not they're not
politics
it's science we have discovered mark
said this we have discovered the science
of history
the science of politics it's not up for
debate how dare you disagree we know the
science of it
and that's what we're going to get we're
going to get new government offices
that pretend to be non-political purely
scientific and they are going to
exert probably greater influence on our
politics than anything else
in our government john kerry and so if
we're going to have these new scientific
offices that we can't
disagree with that are not open to
debate do we think john kerry is the
right guy for this job
some people forget this john kerry has
been wrong about
everything his whole life i don't think
he's ever been right about a single
thing
ever once he's been wrong since he got
back from vietnam
he's been wrong since he was in the
senate he was certainly wrong as
secretary of state do you remember
when john kerry was secretary of state
he's coming into this role he's speaking
at the brookings institution
he comes in and he says that
there is absolutely no way that you're
going to have
peace between israel and arab nations if
you don't deal
first with the palestinian problem now
you'll recall president trump
took a different approach to israel and
the arab world than his predecessors in
obama in bush in clinton in the other
bush in all of these administrations he
trump took a different approach he said
we're not going to deal with the
palestinian problem first we're just
going to deal with israel and the arab
states
john kerry said that was a complete
disaster there's no way that could ever
possibly work take a listen
to secretary of state thurston howell
iii there will be no separate peace
between israel and the arab world i want
to make that very clear to all of you
i've heard several prominent politicians
in israel
sometimes saying well the arab world's
in a different place now we just have to
reach out to them and
we can work some things with the arab
world and we'll deal with the
palestinians no
no no and no
i can tell you that reaffirmed even in
the last week as i have talked to
leaders of the arab community
there will be no advance and separate
peace with the arab world
without the palestinian process and
palestinian peace
everybody needs to understand that that
is a
hard reality that's a hard reality
that was completely disproven over the
past four years
100 shredded over the past four years
donald trump has completely ignored the
palestinian problem
he's just dealt with israel's neighbors
and israel itself
and israel has signed record peace deals
with countless arab neighbors
israel bibi netanyahu leader of israel
just headed over and met with the crown
prince of saudi arabia historic
hasn't happened before trump completely
right kerry completely wrong and kerry
might be
completely infrequently wrong but he's
never in doubt he's always so sure
he has that wasp-ish drawl said i
promise you
lovey lovey i swear to you as i sit here
sipping my pims cup
israel will never have peace in the
middle east
if we do not deal with palestine
thank you lovey and it turned out that
was completely wrong now what sort of
wrong-headed policies will john kerry
pursue as the climate czar
could you imagine our great nation has
been confronted with
unprecedented peril burke said it very
well
all it takes for evil to prevail is for
good people to do nothing
if you want to help preserve america
while you still can join amac
this is the association of mature
american citizens amac
the fastest growing conservative group
in america
joining amac gives you access to money
saving benefits
cutting edge news and a great bi-monthly
magazine but more importantly
amac fights for you if you care about
our future like i do then join aimac
today over two million conservatives
have already joined amac stand with us
by joining right now go to amac dot
u s slash knowles k w l e
s that is a m a c dot u s
slash knowles canada w l e s the
benefits of a mac membership
are great they are terrific but the
cause frankly
is even greater head on over there right
now
join today at amac dot u s slash
knowles k w l e s john kerry he wasn't
just wrong about
the palestinian issue in israel by the
way he was wrong about
moving the embassy you know it was a u.s
policy for decades
that the u.s embassy in israel should be
in jerusalem
in reality it was in tel aviv because
americans were too afraid
to put the embassy where they thought it
would irritate
the palestinian arabs well so donald
trump
makes the same promises as everybody
says i guess i'm supposed to put the
embassy in jerusalem okay sounds good
then he does it i was talking to senator
cruz on our podcast verdict
and apparently when the when the state
department
came in they presented the the arguments
for
for and against moving the embassy in
israel to jerusalem
you had arguments uh for moving it to
jerusalem
zero arguments against moving it to
jerusalem a whole long list
trump does it anyway turns out great and
then a lot of other countries follow
suit and they name a town in israel
after donald trump
who the left still calls an anti-semite
apparently the least successful
anti-semite
in human history john kerry insisted
if you move that embassy you are going
to have
an explosion kerry is also concerned
about the middle east where he spent
nine months trying to secure peace
between the israelis and palestinians
he said the president-elect's campaign
pledged to move the u.s embassy to the
disputed city of jerusalem would inflame
the arab world you'd have an explosion
an absolute explosion in the region
an absolute explosion actually you had
peace you had record peace
as i mentioned just a little bit earlier
on sunday israeli prime minister bibi
netanyahu
met with saudi crown prince mohammed bin
salman
in saudi arabia this is the first
publicly acknowledged meeting
between a prime minister of the israeli
government
and high level officials of the saudi
arabian government
ever ever shocking record piece
if you had told even me four years ago
that donald trump would bring peace to
the middle east
and i voted for trump i supported trump
i i would have laughed
not because i don't think trump you know
is a talented guy just because
i thought it was an intractable problem
that both parties had tried for a long
time to solve well the reason that both
parties couldn't solve it is because
both parties had exactly the same
approach
and trump had a different approach and
the trump approach worked
and now i do fear if trump is ushered
off the stage
i fear that we're going to return to
some kind of uniparty consensus
this same failed consensus among squishy
republicans and liberal democrats
that we've had for decades in this
country
i do like by the way that what president
trump's doing is
sort of hedging his bets here taking the
legal fight to the courts
still claiming that the election was
fraudulent and that he'll he will
prevail in the end
but also uh figuring out
how to get enough um enough of his
preferred deals in place before he
leaves
that joe biden can't screw it up too
much i think a lot of what this meeting
was about as well
is that both israel and saudi arabia
fear a renewed iran nuclear deal
if joe biden becomes president and so
they want to get their affairs in order
before that can possibly happen in any
event great news for
peace in the middle east the trump
presidential transition if
it does end up evolving into a fuller
transition
is somehow not the most shocking and
disturbing
transition going on today the reason for
that is that hbo has a new show
the new show is called trans hood here's
the description
filmed over five years in kansas city
transhood
chronicles the lives of four young
people
aged 15 okay 12
7 and 4
and their families as they navigate
growing up
transgender in america's heartland
four years old transgender
i almost was not going to even play this
clip on the show because it's so
disturbing and these degenerates who
filmed it
and who participated in it these adults
should be in prison
but it's on hbo it's out there the clip
has gone viral and i suppose
just like putting up images of a crime
are helpful to nabbing the perpetrators
i think
we should probably publicize this clip
that's already out there
so that we can bring this to the public
forefront and so that laws can be passed
to make this
illegal take a listen good morning
today we choose to recognize honor love
and celebrate
anyone here who would claim their
identity publicly as lesbian
gay bisexual transgender queer or
questioning
intersex pansexual asexual or any
category that i've left out
this is phoenix
phoenix is looks like four years old
[Music]
phoenix would like you to know that
she's a girl and she prefers she and her
pronouns
go this way may you be well
safe and whole we honor you
exactly as you are
this is so wrong on
every single level and every adult
in that room first of all a law should
be passed against this if you can't
use current child abuse laws you should
create a new law against whatever this
is you should prosecute every single
person in this room every adult
you should throw them in prison and you
should throw away the key
that's it little river
does not want to tell people that this
little boy does not want to tell
people that he's a little girl he
manifestly does not
he says he's too shiny he leaves he
walks away and then his
sociopath mother takes the microphone
and says my
little boy is a little girl and then
these perverts all in a
in a what is obviously a religious
ceremony
a leftist religious ceremony
tell the little boy that he's a little
girl and they give him a little flower
now this is a religion right there
actually is a term for this which is
called gnostic dualism
it's a heresy that i thought was snuffed
out in the west
over a thousand years ago and it
apparently wasn't it's the idea that
uh your physical body has nothing to do
with your true self your true self which
is purely metaphysical so
your body can be entirely male for
instance but your true metaphysical self
is female in some way
it's a it's a it's a ridiculous religion
but it is a religious view
these sickos are forcing that religious
view on these children
and convincing them
and confusing them into believing that
little boys are little girls and little
girls are little boys
and seriously inflicting psychological
damage on them
and there are some people in in this
country there's some people
in the conservative movement who look at
this
and say that it is a blessing of liberty
i kid you not
people who they call themselves
libertarians but i don't
i wouldn't call them libertarians
because i think that's offensive to
libertarian to actual libertarianism
which i'm not a libertarian myself but i
this is something even
more shallow and degraded to say that oh
yes
thomas jefferson and george washington
would love
a bunch of adults abusing little
children and convincing little boys that
they're little girls
that's what they meant when they
described the blessings of liberty that
is not what they meant
when they described the blessings of
liberty and there's a
real issue on the right that we need to
deal with and snuff out
which is this mistaken belief that we
are not allowed to have any views
on moral matters we're not allowed to
have any and we're certainly not allowed
to enforce any views
because you can't legislate morality or
some other bumper slogan nonsense
of course you can not only can you
legislate morality you
necessarily legislate morality all laws
legislate morality from laws about the
death penalty down to parking tickets
all laws weigh in on moral questions
and come to moral conclusions and
enforce those moral conclusions
on the country on the people
and it's in in a way it's the right's
fault that we got this
the left are the aggressors so i don't
want to i don't want to victim blame
here you know
the real victims of the kids but it is
in a way conservative's fault
because what we said is when we were
approached by this radical leftism
which basically goes under the name of
political correctness
we were approached by this a completely
new standard a moral standard a
religious standard a standard of speech
a standard of behavior a standard that
said i'm going to
have drag queen story hour and twerk in
front of four-year-old kids
i'm gonna have men put on dresses and
twerk in front of four-year-old kids and
i'm gonna convince four-year-old kids
that they're the little boys or little
girls
when we were confronted with that
instead of pushing back and saying no
that's wrong
it's morally wrong it's physically
factually wrong
and we're not going to tolerate that
what we said is well
you know look you have your standard and
we have our standards
and there's no way that we can possibly
discern between the two
how there's no way to discern between
good and bad there's no way to
discern between things that lead to
human flourishing and things that lead
to human degradation there's no way to
discern
so we're just going to throw up our
hands and say you do you and
and we do it all in the name of say free
speech for instance
a lot of people are defending this child
abuse on the on the grounds of free
speech
child abuse is not free speech and in in
a way it's our fault because
for a long time maybe two decades now
conservatives
right-wingers have taken this very
shallow and inaccurate reading
of what free speech means in the
american tradition to to suggest that it
means you can say anything at all
anything whatsoever that is not true and
that has never been true and
conservatives have not believed that
except for the past 15 or 20 years or so
there have been whole swaths of speech
that have been illegal in america from
the very beginning and nobody's
disagreed
sedition threats fighting words
fraud all all manner of speech
obscenity obviously obscenity has been
illegal from the very beginning we don't
enforce it very much anymore but it is
this is obscene this is worse than
obscene this is abusive
and if there's nothing hypocritical
hypocritical rather about conservatives
calling that out
and the longer we cowardly in a cowardly
way
stand back throw up our hands and say
well i don't i can't criticize what
you're doing to those kids because then
look if i criticize you for transiting
the kids
you might criticize me for taking my
kids to church
uh okay but one of those things is good
and one of those things is evil
and we can discern we have rational
faculties
there isn't there is objective truth i
know that's unfashionable to say
we have faculties of reason that's also
unfashionable to say
and we can discern not always perfectly
but pretty well
between what is good and what is evil
using those faculties of reason
and we can enforce those views in the
political sphere that's what politics is
for
our founding fathers sure would have
understood that and i can't believe
that we are permitting this right now
that should be illegal we should not
ever ever permit that in this country
hbo should be boycotted that this movie
should be
taken off of the air and the the people
who not only produce the movie forget
that for a second these parents
should be prosecuted
and you should wear soft shirts
buttercloth shirts are not sift
stiff they're not scratchy like typical
men's dress shirts
they feel like you're wearing your
favorite t-shirt they do they are
absolutely fabulous
as i get so riled up in this culture
one thing that makes me feel a little
bit more comfortable are my buttercloth
shirts
i love this shirt you've seen me wear it
many times this revolutionary new fabric
is 100
long fiber cotton with six-way stretch
it's breathable keeps you warm in winter
and cool in summer the signature details
and tailored fit
will make you look amazing butter cloth
caught the attention of abc's hit show
shark tank in 2018
and they love the shirts so much
that they invested a quarter million
dollars 250 000
during covid no one wants to go to the
mall a lot of malls aren't even open
butter cloth is sent to you and if
you're shopping for gifts butter cloth
you can ship to multiple addresses in
one order
i was skeptical of this guys this is a
dress shirt it's an oxford shirt
it is the softest shirt i've ever worn
it's amazing it feels like it would be
some synthetic material that's not
great cotton right now buttercloth is
offering our listeners
up to fifty percent off your first
purchase go to buttercloth.com slash
knowles can wlas
and the discount will be applied at
checkout that is buttercloth.com
knowles k-w-l-e-s to get up to 50
off your first purchase you know
horrible things happening to children on
hbo good things happening to children in
my new state of
tennessee which we'll get to in one
second you know thanksgiving's almost
here
that means that black friday is almost
here too since last year's black friday
deal we've been consistently adding more
features and products to our membership
program
and we're really excited about it we've
added more exclusive readers past
content
our insider and above members can now
stream our content
on apple tv and roku which is exciting
because of all the new content we're
adding like this show going to
drumroll please five days a week this
show is going to five days a week
starting on friday december 4th
very exciting stuff we're also going to
radio by the way which will be a lot of
fun
your account also now comes with custom
badges
that you can earn by participating in
daily wire events you also get two
leftist years tumblers
early access to our daily wire merch and
daily discussions with our writers and
special guests
we're also continuing to add new
features and products like the entire
prageru library which is currently
being added to the website which is good
that includes my show on prageru the
book club
you will get content from candace owens
who's launching a new show with us early
next year
needless to say we're very excited about
this year's deal you do not want to miss
it head over to dailywire.com we'll be
right back with a lot more
some good news fortunately for
especially for young people in
the united states not in whatever kooky
place
and whatever kooky network was was
transiting the kids
but in tennessee a state that i'm loving
more and more
by the minute uh tennessee passed a law
recently banning abortions on the basis
of
race sex and uh prenatal diagnosis of
down syndrome
this was then challenged by the left
which is it's so ironic i felt this
this law was a wonderful law in itself
it did good things in itself but also
wonderful in the way that it trolled the
left because the left always accuses us
what do they say they say we're sexist
we're racist we're ableist that's a new
term
means you're mean to people who have
different handicaps
and then what does the left do the left
tries to abort babies on the basis of
their race their sex and their handicaps
specifically here a prenatal diagnosis
of down syndrome
in iceland so not in the united states
but in iceland they bragged a couple
years ago
that they had eradicated down syndrome
but they they didn't you can't eradicate
down syndrome
it's not like they found a cure for down
syndrome they were bragging that they
killed all the babies that had down
syndrome
and so what this law in tennessee said
is you can't do that that's wrong
it's racist sexist ableist just plain
wrong
and the left sued they said we do want
to be able to kill babies on the basis
of their race
what if we don't like their race we do
want to kill babies on the basis of
their sex
maybe i don't want a daughter we do we
absolutely do want to kill babies on the
basis of their
handicaps what if we want to do that why
how dare
you tell us that we can so this ruling
the this law rather was upheld by an
appeals court
litigation is going to continue but for
now the law is mostly permitted to stay
in effect
and then it will work its way up the
court system this is thanks to the sixth
circuit
court of appeals which lifted part of a
lower court's preliminary injunction
that blocked the law from being forced
so the law now is being enforced
that is a very good thing we are going
to have to weigh in
on these issues in the country okay
we're talking about
transitions trans you know transiting
the administration
transiting the kids and i think a lot of
conservatives
particularly the ones with a very very
very degraded view
of libertarianism a misunderstanding of
libertarianism in large part
they want to pretend that there is some
neutral ground
that we can just live in a neutral
ground a neutral liberal space
and it's a neutral secular space where
everything is fine we can kind of have a
truce and you won't the lefties won't
aggress
and the conservatives won't aggress and
it's we can all just respect one
another's views
that's not how politics works the
law will will decide certain things
the culture will go certain places
either you can kill kids if they have
down syndrome or you can't kill kids if
they have down syndrome
and you've got to weigh in and either
way you rule on that by the way
you are enforcing your morality on
others
you are you are either way some way
either the people who want to kill the
kids with down syndrome are going to
feel coerced into not doing that or the
people who don't want to kill kids with
down syndrome
are going to feel coerced into living in
this culture that slaughters kids with
down syndrome
either way you are going to impose your
morality on others
you have to do it that's a that's one
reality you have to acknowledge the next
one is
we can know good from evil
we have a conscience we have faculties
of reason
we can be educated we have intelligence
less and less every day it seems looking
around the country but we do we do we
have intelligence
we can do that we need confidence and
courage the prerequisite of all the
other virtues
to state that plainly because what we're
seeing around us in our government
is kind of the performance of different
branches different
structures in our government it's a show
i've referred in the past to court
jester conservatives
the conservatives who pretend to oppose
the dominant liberal regime but they
don't really they just when push comes
to shove they roll over
they put up enough limp opposition to
legitimize the regime but ultimately
they roll over
the same is true when you look at the
media the same is true when you look at
the not just news media but the
entertainment media it's a big show
here's a great example of the show
andrew cuomo
is about to win an emmy award
andrew cuomo last i checked he's not in
any movies
he's not in any sitcoms but he's going
to win an
emmy the international emmy awards are
going to give
andrew cuomo an award quote in
recognition
of his leadership during the covid19
pandemic and his masterful use of
television to inform and calm people
around the world well what television oh
because andrew cuomo went on his
brother's show at cnn
and they made jokes with each other and
chris cuomo
tried to cover up his brother's failings
in new york
which led to the directly led to the
deaths of thousands of elderly new
yorkers
made new york the number one leader in
the country
in kovid deaths and as of now the number
two leader in
death rate the only one ahead of him in
death rate is new jersey
another democratic stronghold we'll get
to that in a second
by any measure andrew cuomo did worse on
coronavirus than
pretty much any governor in the whole
country certainly much much worse than
the president
they didn't get the hospitals right
javits center and
the federal hospital ship totally
unnecessary they didn't get the
respirators right they didn't get
anything right
they didn't get a single thing right but
they used the news media
esp specifically cuomo's brother to lie
about the record and the news media gave
him plaudits and now the
entertainment media are going to give
him an award to it's all a big show
disconnected from reality
and liberal republicans remain
completely clueless they go along with
it
they provide limp opposition and then
ultimately
they acquiesce to the true rulers of the
country
the bureaucracy you saw this with the
liberal republican governor
larry hogan larry hogan
big old lib larry hogan
comes out and he says you need to wear a
mask you need to listen to dr fauci
sure we can pretend to be republicans
but you ultimately need to listen to our
technocratic
scientific egghead overlords if you
don't do that you you're basically
guilty of murder well it's it's sort of
like saying i have a constitutional
right
to drive drunk i have a constitutional
right to not wear a seat belt
or to yell fire in a crowded movie
theater
or to not follow the speed limit uh
it's you know we're talking about a
quarter of a million people dying
already you know more than you know the
the
the korean war the gulf war and vietnam
were added together uh
which part don't you understand you wear
the mask it's there's no constitutional
right
to walk around without a mask this is we
did it in in
1918 i don't know why we can't do it now
first of all no we didn't have
nationwide mass mandates in 1918.
how stupid does this guy think we are
but more we also didn't have a
technocratic
uh administrative apparatus in 1918 that
was actually governing us
through the mouthpieces of governors
including liberal republicans like larry
hogan
but but more than that not wearing a
mask is like
driving drunk show me those death rates
buddy i don't i don't think that's true
all the experts were telling us that we
shouldn't wear masks what five six
months ago
now they're telling us we should wear
masks and who knows what they'll tell us
tomorrow
studies coming out questioning the
effectiveness of the masks doesn't
matter
doesn't matter whatever is convenient to
our
technocratic overlords now what's funny
about this everyone's attacking larry
hogan for this including me
but i actually think he's on to a little
something when he says look
we you don't have a right to yell fire
in a crowded theater which is an
extraordinarily overused example but it
gets to what we were saying earlier
there are limits
on well on everything because this is a
limited bounded world
from the very beginning of our country
all the way to the present there have
been huge swaths of speech we're not
allowed to say
there's been plenty of things that we're
not allowed to do i used to be very
frustrated by this as a little kid
back when people still said but this is
a free country remember when kids would
say that
and i would say i'd say wait what do you
mean there's a speed limit this is a
free country what do you mean there's a
traffic light this is a free country
but of course i had a childish view of
freedom
which a lot of people have today and
what is what the founding fathers had is
an adult view of freedom
an exalted freedom a freedom in ordered
liberty a freedom in justice
freedom that does not just have us
pursuing our appetites willy-nilly but a
freedom that gives us the right to do
what we ought to do
the question here for larry hogan is
where's the law about the masks where is
the tradition about the masks where is
the what is the argument for the masks
they haven't made a very good one
it's capricious rulings from governors
and worse usually rulings with very
little
binding effect and worse capricious
rulings from
eggheads who actually have no democratic
accountability at all
that is that is beyond our
constitutional framework that is beyond
our our democratic and republican
political norms that's why we should
ignore those stupid things
these guys themselves tend not to
believe their own bs they tend not to
to believe their own press releases
you've seen time and again nancy pelosi
flouts her lockdown rules
nancy pelosi won't wear the mask gavin
newsom flouts his lockdown rules gavin
newsom refuses
often to wear the mask chris cuomo
pretended that he was locked up
quarantining from coronavirus he
actually
was walking around riding bicycles
around the hamptons and getting into
fights with people who called him out
for it
again and again and again we see this
now we just saw the new jersey
democratic governor
who was phil murphy who was just
confronted for not wearing a mask and
for going out to dinner and having a
nice night with his family
and women who maybe they had a couple
too many
and you know had a couple coca-colas at
dinner and in classic new jersey style
got right up in his face about it oh my
gosh hey how you doing
how are you doing you're having fun with
your family in the meantime you're
having all kind of other [ __ ] going
on
you know why i don't need a mask because
there ain't nothing like stronger i like
your trump okay
guess who
okay so i i will say in general i don't
like it when
angry people come up to public figures
in restaurants i just think it's
it's just wrong it's uncivilized it's
unseemly you shouldn't do it even some
jerk like phil murphy especially when
he's with his family
i do think that is wrong i don't think
people should do that sort of thing
the reason i even bring this video up
though is phil murphy's response
phil murphy is sitting there having
dinner
got his family at no mask obviously and
then this woman comes up and gives him a
piece of her mind
and he says excuse me can you please put
the mask on
can you please put the mask on why don't
you put the mask on how come she's gotta
wear a mask but you don't need to wear a
mask
and what's funny is you see later in the
video he realizes he's being filmed then
he puts the mask on
he didn't have the mask on before of
course the mask
issue in restaurants is completely
preposterous the way it works now is you
walk up to a restaurant
and then right before you walk you don't
have the mascot and then you walk in the
door and you have to put the mask on
and you talk to the hostess you walk to
your table
so you walk 10 feet to your table you
have to have the mask on
then you sit down at the table and you
enter an invisible
orb of health and sanitation
whereby you can take the mask off and
you can breathe freely
the virus cannot penetrate the magical
orb of the dinner table
you see and the waiters and the busters
and the kitchen runners are going to
come and go and that but that
doesn't matter you can't get the virus
you can't give the virus
because you're in the magical orb but
then the minute you get up to use
the restroom or to leave the restaurant
you have to you have to put the mask
back on
now this doesn't make any sense at all
and phil murphy the governor was showing
that
he's saying no i'm sitting at the at the
magical dinner table so i can't give you
coronavirus
but you because you're standing up eight
inches away from me
you have to wear the mask completely
incoherent
i'm not even totally disagreeing with
guys like larry hogan or the people who
say we need to
you don't have a constitutional right
not to wear a mask the police does have
certain powers and pandemics yeah sure
okay that's fine
i want to get into the details about
this what's the argument for the mask
how come you keep contradicting your own
rules how come you keep violating your
own rules for that matter
now all of a sudden i'm much much less
likely to follow what you're saying
because they have no credibility
whatsoever neither the governors who
enforcing these things
nor the experts who are pulling the
puppet strings
uh newsom nussolini i'm so glad i left
that state
which is now being locked down they're
going to end up closing all the
restaurants permanently probably
newsom you know before he
amid all of his different lockdown
orders decided to go have a nice little
fancy dinner with a friend of his at the
french laundry
michelin rated restaurant it was about
350
per plate at least unless you want the
delicious little gnocchi edition that
costs another 150 bucks
and i i've heard it's worth it i've
never been myself but
gavin seemed like he had a good night so
what gavin newsom said we played it on
the show a few days ago
is that he went to this dinner and he
thought it was going to be fewer people
and it was going to be outside you know
and
but he made a mistake he shouldn't have
sat down but look it was basically fine
and it really didn't violate the rules
but
anyway he probably shouldn't have done
it now we found out from an
award-winning journalist adam housley
who is from the town that this
restaurant's in apparently
he says because yountville is my
hometown and where the french laundry is
located i thought i'd do some digging
facts about the newsome dinner the bar
bill was around fifteen thousand dollars
fifteen thousand dollars that is more
even than i could drink i always thought
it was pretty good
22 people in attendance not 12 as
previously reported
no masks all indoors they got so loud
other patrons complained
there was zero effort to go outside and
there was no social distancing of any
type
i'm also told that some of those there
are now privately laughing at the
controversy of course they all are
remember this is my little hometown the
walls speak i mention all of this
because
for all of these stories the trans kids
story on hbo the transition story maybe
we're seeing a presidential
administration from trump i hope not but
there might be a world you know we have
to deal with the distinct and more than
distinct possibility that biden's going
to be the next president
the government that we are looking at
and kerry's appointment alleged
appointment as
the climates are is the is the little
cherry on top of this awful sunday
the government that we're looking at is
one of absolutely
capricious radical incoherent
technocratic policy that will be outside
the bounds of
democratic politics even more so than it
already is
it will be it will effectively be an
oligarchy
whereby the experts who have special
privileges and
little accountability will play by one
set of rules
all the rest of us will be expected to
play by another set of rules and they
can change the rules of the game
at any time that is a transition
not just transiting the poor little kids
not just transiting one administration
to another but transitioning away from a
constitutional government
toward a progressive technocratic
government
this is explicitly what woodrow wilson
called for in the early days of the
progressive movement
this is what the left has clamored for
for a hundred years
and we appear to be on the verge of
getting it that is
a transition that none of us can
tolerate
and we appear to be on the cusp of it
have to be very very vigilant
we have to be very vigilant to try to
hold the senate
we have to be very very vigilant to try
to hold the presidency if we still can
let the legal process play out
that that is a transition that it would
seem very difficult
to ever come back from that's our show
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire
20 20. hey everybody it's andrew clavin
host of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
is turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton